[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Christelle Baffie
participant au raid des étoiles du
Verdon du 18 au 22 juin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes trois à participer à la
troisième édition du Raid des étoiles du
Verdon au mois de au mois de juin pour
cette aventure le raid est 100% féminins
il est destiné à tout niveau sportif
alors comment est-ce que vous avez connu
justement ce serait des pourquoi vouloir
y participer alors moi j'ai pas connu le
raid en fait c'est les filles donc
Morgane et Amélie mais coéquipières qui
m'ont présenté un peu le raid qui m'ont
dit on cherche une troisième coéquipière
voilà et du coup j'ai complètement
adhéré alors déjà moi personnellement le
Verdon en fait j'y suis jamais allée et
en fait c'est une région de France qui
me voilà qui m'a toujours fascinée et
d'ailleurs il y a deux ans sauf qu'il y
a eu covid du coup on n'a pas pu le
faire mais on voulait participer avec
mon compagnon faire du kayak en fait sur
le Verdon et finalement ça s'est pas
fait donc voilà donc déjà
ça a été ça a été le déclencheur et puis
bah moi je me suis mise au sport il y a
pas très longtemps et du coup c'était un
challenge sportif féminin entre copie et
voilà et donc donc moi j'ai adhéré et
voilà alors justement on va on va vous
présenter et présenter vos coéquipières
en quelques mots donc qui êtes-vous et
qu'est-ce qui vous a motivé à participer
là vous en avez un petit peu parlé c'est
peut-être aussi un peu la découverte le
challenge aussi qui vous motive moi
clairement c'est le challenge ouais
c'est le challenge sportif alors pas
forcément dans la performance mais dans
le dépassement de soi parce que bon moi
je me suis mise au sport il y a trois
ans donc finalement au niveau résultat
je veux dire je vais pas attendre un
résultat extrême extrêmement bon mais
par contre voilà le challenge un peu de
dépassement de soi de se prouver de de
qu'on peut faire des choses en dehors
d'être maman et de notre travail et puis
aussi le côté
le côté fun entre copines aussi pendant
une semaine voilà on va toutes les trois
à se dépasser toutes les trois et voilà
et qui sont vos coéquipières justement
qui a Amélie du coup Amélie qui vit à
Lyon donc voilà
on a toute la quarantaine à peu près
elle est maman d'un petit garçon de 18
mois voilà donc c'est assez récent donc
c'est pareil Amélie elle a fait beaucoup
de sport en fait
à la trentaine et puis après bah il y a
eu projet bébé il y a eu le bébé tout ça
donc du coup bah un peu moins de sport
donc le
raid en fait c'est aussi un défi pour
elle je pense pour et puis aussi un
objectif en fait pour se remettre au
sport
voilà et puis la dernière coéquipière
donc Morgane qui est notre capitaine en
fait d'équipe donc elle qui a un profil
un peu différent d'une autre puisqu'elle
est très sportive en fait et qu'elle a
fait du sport depuis son enfance
euh régulièrement et donc voilà il
Morgan allez maman de deux enfants
d'une petite fille et d'un petit garçon
et voilà et à vie à Herblay voilà alors
justement on va parler un petit peu de
votre préparation donc il y a deux
sportives amatrices finalement une autre
sportive un peu plus confirmée c'est
justement Morgan qui qui vous motive
pour pour la préparation comment est-ce
que vous êtes préparés notamment avec
une des trois qui vit à Lyon alors du
coup c'est vrai qu'on peut pas tellement
se rassembler même avec Morgane qui
vient Herblay parce que finalement c'est
un petit peu loin aussi de chez moi et
puis bon ben voilà entre la vie
professionnelle la vie de maman la vie
de famille etc on ça nous laisse pas
beaucoup de temps de se rencontrer on
l'a fait deux trois fois mais voilà pas
si souvent que ça par contre on essaye
d'avoir des voilà de de savoir au
téléphone assez régulièrement et
effectivement
Morgane voilà nous motive et puis nous
donne des conseils en tant que sportive
et voilà
donc voilà on s'auto motive on essaye de
s'auto motiver et puis par exemple je me
souviens d'une fois où moi j'étais plus
très motivée à aller courir avec du coup
je me suis de au club de course de
Guyancourt et j'étais pas très motivé à
y aller et puis Morgane elle me dit bon
bah moi je vais à la natation et donc
voilà ça ça a déclenché je me suis bon
allez là moi j'y vais c'est sûr on n'est
pas très loin justement durée des
étoiles du Verdon donc c'est organisé du
18 au 22 juin on a parlé un petit peu de
votre de votre préparation mais quels
sont les épreuves qui vous attendent
lors de cette événement alors les
épreuves elles sont diverses donc c'est
des épreuves donc de natation de course
à pied de vélo il va y avoir aussi pas
dol kayak il va y avoir un petit peu de
parcours du combattant des choses comme
ça voilà ça peut être c'est vraiment
diversifié donc
voilà et ça peut être à tout moment et
donc la particularité aussi du raid
c'est que nous on ne sait pas en fait ce
qui nous attend donc voilà les épreuves
on sait que ça peut aller jusqu'à 15 km
de course à pied par exemple
20 km de vélo je crois qu'on a entendu
aussi 10 km de kayak ce qui est pas
négligeable pour nous
mais voilà on ne sait pas quand ça
arrivera ça peut être la nuit aussi donc
voilà c'est 72 heures vraiment
où tout peut arriver où on va nous dire
au dernier moment allez on va on épreuve
et vous allez faire ça et voilà ce que
vous adaptez justement votre votre
entraînement vu qu'il n'y a pas que de
la course à pied comment est-ce que vous
adapté l'entraînement du coup bon on a
fait comme on a pu aussi avec les moyens
qu'on avait à côté et le temps aussi
qu'on avait donc je pense que toutes les
trois vraiment on est sur la course à
pied voilà
la natation aussi moi cette année j'ai
un petit peu j'en faisais beaucoup
l'année dernière et cette année c'est
vrai que j'ai un petit peu réduit mais
en tout cas je compte bien y retourner
quand même maintenant avec les beaux
jours ça va être plus motivant d'y
retourner du coup avant le raid donc
c'est surtout la natation la course à
pied moi je me suis inscrite aussi au
club de kayak du coup de Trappes
j'ai pas eu l'occasion encore d'y aller
parce que bon Steven il faisait un peu
froid quand même donc j'ai évité d'y
aller mais je compte y aller un petit
peu avant le raid et voilà en gros c'est
un peu les trois mots clés ou plutôt
valeur de l'événement sont solidaires
féminines et nature que vous inspire
c'est ces valeurs
solidaire déjà c'est effectivement grâce
à l'association des Petits Princes qu'on
va pouvoir mettre en avant du coup donc
l'association des Petits Princes qui
est là pour réaliser les rêves des
enfants malades en fait
voilà féminine bah nous ça nous parle
parce que effectivement en tant que
maman le quotidien il est pas toujours
facile il faut toujours bien entre tout
et du coup voilà on est très content de
participer
à un événement sportif 100% féminin ce
qui est pas si courant en fait et voilà
donc on est content de mettre en valeur
on est content de mettre en valeur ça et
puis et puis la terre
voilà effectivement on est sensible
forcément à l'écologie surtout quand on
voit ce qui se passe en ce moment
avec bon notamment les pistes de ski la
dernière manque était quand même
[Musique]
désormais j'ai du coup on voit bien
qu'il y a vraiment un problème
climatique de réchauffement climatique
voilà et d'ailleurs dans notre nom en
fait d'équipe qui est légère dentaire on
a mis l'accent sur terre qui a plusieurs
donc il y avait déjà un jeu de mots sur
Verdon où c'était donc le Verdon et puis
vers de terre et donc il y avait la
terre effectivement qui nous tenait à
cœur et puis le terre qui est qui veut
dire 3 aussi voilà et finalement
l'association Les Petits Princes en tant
que en tant que maman vous êtes toutes
les trois mamans vous a aussi touché
vous a un peu pas motivé à participer
mais vous un peu plus touché dans cette
dans cette motivation disons que oui on
s'est retrouvé complètement parce que on
s'est dit oui ça c'est les valeurs alors
on n'a pas d'enfants malades
nous mais effectivement ça nous touche
forcément enfin et donc voilà d'égayer
la vie donc
l'association des Petits Princes
effectivement essaie de réaliser des
rêves des pour les enfants malades donc
notamment
voilà ça peut être un tour en avion ça
peut être rencontrer leur chanteur
préféré des choses comme ça et ouais bah
nous on se met à la place on verrait
notre petit nos petites têtes blondes
effectivement
réaliser leurs rêves du coup
voilà c'est il y a c'est quelque chose
de plutôt qui nous touche ouais c'est
sûr et donc vous êtes suivi par trois
sponsors vos proches également vous vous
soutiennent dans cette dans cette
démarche dans cet événement nos proches
nous soutiennent oui oui bah déjà Amélie
donc son son compagnon
du coup nous a sponsor aussi du coup
donc c'est la boucherie marchand
qui est près de Roanne
donc voilà et puis nous soutiennent
parce que ils essayent de nous dégager
du temps aussi pour
pour qu'on puisse entraîner voilà
voilà alors la dernière petite question
c'est un conseil peut-être aux femmes
qui n'osent pas se ce qui n'osent pas
participer à ce rêve en quelques mots
quelles sont les conseils qu'il faut
donner à ces femmes
je pense qu'il faut pas trop réfléchir
non après je pense que vraiment il faut
que voilà c'est vraiment ça permet en
fait aussi d'avoir une parenthèse dans
sa vie et du coup enfin moi en tout cas
c'est comme ça que je le vis d'avoir une
parenthèse et
puis de pas avoir peur du défunt je
pense que l'idée de ce raide justement
c'est vraiment ouvert à tout le monde et
c'est pas de faire forcément des
résultats nous en tout cas on n'y va pas
forcément pour ça puisque on sait qu'on
est enfin voilà il y a Morgan qui est
très sportif et puis Amélie et moi qui
sommes voilà un peu moins sportive le
but c'est vraiment de participer à un
événement de partage aussi entre copines
pour pour y participer merci beaucoup
Christelle Baffie sensation et pour pour
voir pardon réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]